[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le journal
de l'afrique édition spéciale ce soir
consacré au retour de blaise compaoré au
burkina faso retour après huit ans
d'exil l'ancien président déchu doit
participer à une rencontre d'aix chef
d'état burkinabè pour parler
réconciliation nationale mais vous
verrez que ce retour fait polémique car
blaise compaore est sous le coup d'une
condamnation par contumace à la prison à
vie pour son rôle dans l'assassinât de
son prédécesseur thomas sankara nous
irons dans ce journal à ouagadougou
retrouver abdoulaye barry notre
correspondant tellines aussi ancien
correspondant au burkina se ralliant en
plateau tout comme l'avocat de blaise
compaore maître pierre olivier sur et
nous serons aussi avec m guy hervé kam
avocat des familles de victimes dans la
sphère sankara
cela fait donc huit ans qu'il n'avait
pas foulé le sol de son pays blaise
compaoré est arrivé tout à l'heure à
ouagadougou l'ancien président a voyagé
depuis abidjan dans un avion mis à sa
disposition par la côte d'ivoire est en
exil on va écouter tout de suite
quelques réactions de ses partisans à
son arrivée un vol de deux bouts
c'est même pas du bon c'est pas qu'on
m'a dit merci dieu et même s'il
n'atteint chef de l'état et le colonel
et colle à lisandro le président damiba
a choisi ouiiiii tous les anciens
présidents
il sait quelque chose qui doit apprendre
ce jeu puisque lapin 9e le président
blaise compaore a travaillé durant 27
ans pour ce pays sous son règne que vous
qu'il a été a pesé on peut dire que
toute la sous région étaient appelés
et voilà du coup on va tout de suite
retrouvé notre correspondant abdoulaye
barry abdoulaye bonsoir au delà de ses
partisans convient d'entendre quel
accueil a été réservé à l'ancien
président au 27 ans de règne
comme vous l'avez noté soit il y a trois
burkina faso on a d'un côté junte au
pouvoir et les partisans de blaise
compaore qui ont donc réservé un accueil
donc le voir fouler le
1 qui n'a aucune habits haute et en al
karama ans rd32 dit aujourd'hui et non
et aussi
abdoulaye barry on a un petit problème
de connexion avec vous on essaiera de
vous retrouver dans quelques instants à
ouagadougou kalidou sy bonsoir vous êtes
un journaliste france24 ancien
correspondant au burkina faso on l'a vu
donc un accueil plutôt chaleureux de la
part de ses partisans mais le pays reste
tout de même divisée sur sa venue oui ça
n'a que partage et on peut dire que ses
partisans dans accueilli une dizaine de
personnes plusieurs dizaines de
personnes d'ailleurs leur accueil à
l'aéroport de ouagadougou même s'ils
n'ont pas pu l'apercevoir il était là et
chanter exprimé leur joie
quant au retour de ce qu'ils considèrent
comme l'homme fort l'homme fort africain
efforts du burkina faso et dans le côté
on a eu les associations de victimes et
l'association des victimes du procès de
thomas sankara et certaines associations
des droits de l'homme qui se sont
insurgés contre la venue de blaise
compaore car rappelons que blaise
compaore a été condamné à la prison à
vie par contumace lors du verdict du
procès thomas sankara que c'était le 6
avril dernier au burkina faso le procès
s'est tenu pendant six mois de octobre à
avril 2022 d'ailleurs lors du procès il
ne s'est pas présenté car ses avocats
nous avons la personne de pierre olivier
sur sedan le plateau avait évoqué une
juridiction explique 2 d'exception et un
procès politique m pierre olivier sur
bonsoir vous êtes l'avocat de blaise
compaore merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
sur sur ce plateau blaise compaoré à
kalidou sy viens de le dire n'était pas
présent lors de ce procès l'assassinât
de thomas sankara la quatre mois après
cette condamnation par contumace
finalement il est de retour dans son
pays qu'est ce qui a changé
écoutez n'était pas présent au procès
mais il est présent face à l'histoire
face à la grande histoire du burkina
faso qui doit se tourner vers l'avenir
et non pas vers le passé l'avenir c'est
quoi c'est une nation qui
aujourd'hui a le devoir de lutter contre
l'ennemi qui ronge cette nation cet
ennemi vient de l'extérieur il s'est
infiltrée à l'intérieur et il est humble
c'est bien tandis qu'il y à des
exactions tous les jours des attentats
tous les jours au burkina que l'esprit
de nation l'esprit du burkina soit
réunie autour de la continuité ses
anciens présidents de la république qui
ont fait du burkina faso un grand pays
pour montrer qu'ils sont là montrer
qu'ils sont là autour du lieutenant
colonel le président de la république
damiba et montrer que et bien l'unité de
la nation fait la force d'aujourd'hui et
l'espoir de demain un mandat d'arrêt a
tout de même été émis à l'encontre de
blaise compaoré votre client ça signifie
qu'une fois sur le sol burkinabè la
police peut l'arrêter à tout moment est
ce que vous avez eu des garanties de la
part des autorités qui ne sera pas
arrêté d arrivée avec un avion officiel
qui a été affrété par la côte d'ivoire
une fois qu'il a retrouvé le sol de son
pays et qu'il a entendu le cri de ses
supporters c'est un hélicoptère qui l'a
amenée jusqu'au palais présidentiel
vous imaginez bien qu'on est très loin
d'un mandat d'arrêt kalidou sy
cette ce retour de blaise compaoré il
intervient m pierre olivier sur
l'évoquait parce qu'il ya cette réunion
prévue d'ici la fin de la semaine dans
un but de réconciliation nationale face
à la recrudescence des attaques 10 à 10
dans le pays où on est vraiment dans une
réconciliation parce que on va rappeler
contexte le président dany bas est
arrivé au pouvoir le 24 janvier 2022 il
a fait un coup d'état contre son
précédesseur roch marc christian kaboré
car il estimait que roch marc christian
kaboré ne pouvait pas assurer la
sécurité du burkina faso sauf que six
mois après il est lui-même confronté à
un regain de violences qui a fait plus
de 100 victimes que ce soit civil ou
militaire donc aujourd'hui il adopte une
stratégie c'est la stratégie de la
réconciliation en disant que nous avons
des ennemis communs qui sont les groupes
terroristes qui mène une sécurité dans
le pays donc d'abord faisons la paix
entre nous ensuite nous irons ensemble
combattre ces groupes là pour un burkina
faso meilleur dans les prochaines années
sauf que et donc on met de côté les sept
condamnations qui date d'avril dernier
sauf que le problème se trouve que
blaise compaore et condamnés ça c'est un
fait à la prison à vie donc plusieurs de
ces des avocats des familles de victimes
et surtout des organisations des droits
de l'homme à juste titre de monde que
blaise compaoré soit arrêté une fois
qu'il a foulé le burkina faso ça c'est
la loi qui le dit mais on imagine que
alassane ouattara qui a toujours refusé
son extradition car n'oublions pas que
blaise compaore était en côte d'ivoire
alassane ouattara le président ivoirien
a toujours refusé son extradition s'il a
accepté que blaise compaoré reviennent
aujourd'hui burkina faso c'est qu'il a
obtenu des garanties des autorités
actuelles nous sommes avec eux m guy
hervé kam avocat des familles de
victimes dans la sphère thomas sankara
maître guy hervé kam bonsoir merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous sur france 24
les militaires au pouvoir au burkina ont
relancé le dossier de la réconciliation
alors que les attaques jihadistes ont
besoin d'en parler se multiplient dans
le pays blaise compaoré doit participer
à une réunion avec d'anciens chefs
d'état d'ici la fin de la semaine est ce
que vous comprenez que dans le cadre de
cette démarche son retour était
incontournable
excusez moi j'ai pas bien entendu la fin
de votre question vous demandez est ce
que est ce que vous comprenez que dans
le cadre de cette démarche de
réconciliation nationale démarche
affichée par les militaires au pouvoir
le retour de blaise compaoré était
incontournable
vous comprenez bien que nous nous en
tenons absolument à rien dans la mesure
où vous parler de réconciliation
nationale au niveau n'est des victimes
des familles des victimes la au niveau
des défenseurs de droits de l'homme on
se pose la question de savoir en fait il
s'agit des cas de conciliation et de
consultation avec qui nous ces jeunes
s'en vont c'est ce que jusqu'au moment
où je vous parle aucune des familles des
victimes n'a été impliqué dans ce
processus au fond blaise compaore ils se
réconcilient avec qui
peut-être qu'il sert possible et avec la
junte au pouvoir qui après donc le coup
d'état depuis le 20 janvier
2022 avait pour lettre de mission de le
faire revenir ils n'ont pas pu empêcher
la fin du procès
moi c'est qu'ils ont réussi quand même
vous rencontrer blaise compaore vous
aussi une façon pour les familles de
victimes c'est totalement l
compréhensible que tu as cherché dans
bien que putschistes qui a prêté serment
de respecter les lois du pays se
transforme en personne qui viole ses
lois en faisant rentrer un condamné et
en hommes et en prenant toutes les
dispositions pour que le mandat d'arrêt
qui a contre lui ne puisse pas être
exécutée vous l'avez dit vous-même les
comparer l avion s est imposée à la base
aérienne un hélicoptère de l'armée est
venu le prélever là-bas pour la main la
présidence il s'agit là tout simplement
d'une complicité politique pour
soustraire blaise compaore dé la justice
et pour encore ouvrir la souffrance des
victimes et de tous les défenseurs des
droits de l'homme dans notre pays vous
estimez ça ressemble à une forme d'
amnistie
dont vous estimez que ça ressemble à une
forme d' amnistie à son encontre
mais non ça ne peut pas ressembler à une
amnistie et d'une amnistie est une
procédure tout à fait légale ici les
différents états connaissent et sont
même totalement la marche de la justice
qu'on peut l'être se sont mis au service
de la justice kalachnikov sinon ici il
n'ya pas de démarche d' amnistie
l'investît est une procédure légale
prévue par les textes bien entendu dans
le cas de blaise compaore on ne sait
rien une loi d'amnistié ne peut pas être
prise parce que la procédure judiciaire
est en pause ça sera une défection dans
la justice tout comme une grâce ne peut
pas être prise parce que les décisions
contre lui ne sont pas définitives et
bien c'est qu'ils aient choisi c'est
vraiment les terrains du nom doit tout
simplement
m pierre-olivier sûr qu'est ce que vous
répondez à ça quand on entend m guy
hervé kam parler de terrain du non droit
je pense que le président d'un mba se
marche sur les traces de nelson mandela
c'est là bas qu'on a inventé qu'on a mis
en place cette réconciliation nationale
pour que une union de la nation
permettent au pays d'avancer et non pas
de regarder toujours dans le rétroviseur
et quand on regarde que dans le
rétroviseur soit on fait de la marche
arrière soit on prend le mur et le mur
aujourd'hui c'est celui du terrorisme
alors avec le président ou aidera au go
avec le président kaffrine dos avec eux
président roch avait un président
campaoré sous l'égide du nouveau chef de
l'état vont se réunir demain ils vont se
réunir demain pour montrer que la
continuité au delà des drames au delà
des soubresauts de l'histoire n'est pas
un vain mot et que le burkina faso est
un pays qui comme la france comme les
états unis comme tous les pays ont eu
des hauts et des bas mais existent et
lève la tête mais s'est levé la tête
c'est regarder deux qu'est ce que tout
ça peut se faire
malgré cette condamnation qui datent
seulement d'avril dernier qu'on ait la
condamnation à la prison à vie oui
est-ce qu'on peut oublier ça alors vous
savez que cette condamnation nous
n'avons pas reconnu vous savez que si
nous n'avons pas reconnu c'est que nous
n'avons pas été convoqué au procès vous
savez que avant le procès lié une phase
d'instruction à laquelle on n'a même pas
été invité à participer et que par
conséquent nous avons toujours indiqué
qu'il s'agissait d'un procès qui n'en
était pas un au regard des droits d'un
procès équitable et c'est la raison pour
laquelle d'ailleurs nous n'avons même
pas formé appel c'est la raison aussi
pour laquelle nous n'avons pas saisi les
juridictions internationales c'est un
procès c'est un verdict non écrit au
regard de tous nos grands principes et
c'est parce que c'est un verdict non
écrit que la grande histoire doit lui
passer dessus et u passant dessus et
bien c'est le retour de blaise campaoré
non pas vainqueur mais apaisé pour une
union nationale et je crois que le
burkina bien besoin de ça aujourd'hui et
nous saluons cette initiative que nous
avons appelée de nos voeux depuis il y a
fort longtemps
kelly dossier vous vouliez réagir
ensuite on ira or tendra à ouagadougou
donc si j'ai bien compris m est ce que
vous vous remettez en cause la justice
burkinabè non je ne remets pas en cause
la justice burkinabè mais lorsqu'il y a
des parenthèses de l'égalité dans
l'histoire pendant ces parenthèses
évidemment la justice n'est pas rendue
de façon légale et la preuve c'est que
entre le début et la fin de la procédure
il ya eu un coup d'état est la preuve de
la preuve c'est que pendant la mise en
oeuvre de ce coup d'état la constitution
a été les effets la constitution est
élevé dès lors le procès ne se fondent
plus sur un beau un blog juridique
et ce procès est à mes yeux
comment dirais-je a donné lieu à un
verre deux noms écrits au regard du
droit international
on va partir à ouagadougou retrouver
abdoulaye barry abdoulaye le retour de
blaise compaore même si il est bref un
on ne sait pas combien de temps
exactement il va rester dans le pays il
pourrait avoir des conséquences
politiques au burkina faso oui on va
assister désormais à une sorte de
redistribution des cartes à une
polarisation de la situation politique
au burkina puisque notons que depuis
l'arrivée de la junte au pouvoir le 24
janvier il y avait une sorte d'accalmie
il y avait un environnement apaisé une
situation politique apaisée mais
désormais les dignes devrait bouger et
des dés aujourd'hui à l'unité d'action
syndicale cadet d'à a lancé un mot
d'ordre est diffile a hanté n'est pas un
modèle mais dénonce donc le fait que la
junte au pouvoir sacrifie la justice
dont sous l'autel de la réconciliation
dans la fin des familles voire même les
partisans de thomas sankara et les
défenseurs des droits de l'homme devrait
pouvoir se faire entendre dans les jours
à venir on peut dire que ce pack à
d'accalmie qui était au burkina jusque
là vient d'être rampe
d'être comparée qui est sous quand même
les mandats d'arrêt le tabassera après
avoir été condamné à la perpétuité par
contumace
devrait aujourd'hui d'abord regarder ce
qui se passe dans le pays en termes
d'insécurité et souhaité la paix et une
paix durable et comprendre que cette
paix passe par une réconciliation
nationale
j'aimerais qu'on retrouve maître guy
hervé kam avocat des familles de
victimes dans la sphère thomas sankara
maître guy hervé kam
est ce que vous avez prévu de réagir
dans les jours qui viennent vous avez
prévu des actions
certainement seulement nous avons déjà
rencontré le coeur de la justice
militaire aujourd'hui tu nous a assuré
que consent pas il y avait un mandat
d'arrêt et que le malade devait être
exécuté nous comprenons aujourd'hui que
nous sommes un état où l'autorité
politique par nature il est dans son adn
puisque c'est une autorité putschistes
que l'autorité politique n'est pas dans
une optique d'état de droite et que par
conséquent il va sans doute falloir agir
par d'autres moyens et bien pas moins
d'affaires de 8 en quatre ans depuis 35
ans pour obtenir la justice c'est comme
un recommencement rapport aux familles
des victimes qui sont résilients qui se
sont toujours battus et bien je peux
vous assurer que accompagné de tous les
défenseurs des droits de l'homme qui
sont encore déterminé à se battre pour
que force reste à la loi permettez moi
avant de terminer de rétablir la mémoire
des nerfs sont mandela qui risque d'être
souillé par ce qui s'est dit nelson
mandela n'a jamais fait une
réconciliation
en musique le processus de
réconciliation en afrique du sud à une
réconciliation
ceux qui se montrent qu'au burkina sans
son célèbre maillot conciliation je n'ai
pas posé cette vérité justice
réconciliation
c'est tout simplement un et mis en scène
en temps entre amis tiers qui avait
perdu le pouvoir qui ont fait un coup
d'état pour prendre le pouvoir et qu'il
se rétablit et à leurs toits je rappelle
pierre étudié l'histoire des enfants des
étudiants
on n'a pas pardonné des poules à vous
entendre on ne va pas réconcilier avec
les poules à bout on a jugé les poules
en ville on les a condamnés c'est ce qui
fait la france dès qu'elle est
aujourd'hui
merci j'avais un petit peu de raison
concernant un président qui a tenu le
pays pendant 27 ans qui a fait du
burkina faso est un grand pays reconnus
sur la scène internationale dont la
culture est aujourd'hui admiré et c'est
ce grand pays la con dont nous aimerions
voir renaître de ses cendres grâce à une
unité nationale et mettre en échec les
tentative mortifère des terroristes et
c'est ce que les défenseurs des droits
de l'homme n'a plu devrait comprendre
aujourd'hui c'est ça les droits merci
beaucoup m pierre-olivier sûr merci
d'avoir été avec nous merci kalidou sy
merci maître guy hervé kam merci
également à douille barry notre
correspondant c'est la fin de ce journal
de l'afrique rester avec nous sur
france24 l'information continue
[Musique]